within the last month I found out that
my husband has actually committed what
the term is uh Financial
infidelity um to the to the tune of
$50,000 oh wow um so he had run up
credit cards got a $117,000 personal
loan to pay them off last year and then
ran them up ran it up again to $24,000
another
$24,000 loan this year uh just two
months ago when somebody cheats on you
whether with another person whether with
money whether with any number of things
I think you can cheat on your wife with
a golf course I think you cheat on your
wife with work right with the office I
think you can cheat on your wife with a
whole bunch of stuff or cheat on your
husband with a whole bunch of stuff I
think um honestly we so narrowly Define
fidelity into the act of some sort of
sexual act I think infidelity is way
bigger than that